you know I'm fascinated by this because
for years you played a doctor and like
for a long time for a minute yeah seven
years that's a long time it's a minute
yes right and you play a doctor and
you've switched now you're still the
same character yes but you've moved on
and changed your role to the firefighter
to a firefighter you're a doctor that
became a firefighter which happens all
the time
it does happen all the time depends are
that big pay kick up yeah I'm tired of
saving lives I know I
but anyway so here's my question when
you I've heard of some other people who
play doctors that they start to sort of
develop the characteristics of a doctor
if you do it for long enough in the
confidence of a doctor and then when
people see you on TV playing a doctor
they kind of there's a sort of a sense
of like oh yeah he could kind of do it
if he had to do it people assume that
you actually know what you're doing yeah
which is a huge mistake don't ever do
that right um yeah I mean I was actually
on a plane one time and the thing that
occasionally happens you hope it never
does but you know somebody started
having a medical issue on the plane
right and so they did they the message
went out is there a doctor on the plane
and the funny part was there's a little
part of me that was like who's gonna
look at me yeah he's gonna look at me
right and it didn't happen right it was
a little disappointed yeah and then they
you know they got the issue rectified
they found a real doctor and I know we
went in the flight we landed we got off
the plane and person was okay person was
okay everybody lived and then I'm
walking through the airport and I came
across the flight attendants and they
walked up they were like hey we're off
the plane now so I just want you to know
I love Grey's Anatomy
I love the new show um can I get a photo
yeah oh by the way I almost got you for
the medical some part of you that would
want to get involved you know I mean
you'd want to get up there and just do
some chess you weren't really yeah I'm
CPR with the best of them yeah yeah I'll
pound your chest all day long what okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you